[Música]
punto en común
adinerados pobres un paso adelante si
están de acuerdo ser pobre es una
elección
no quiero que parezca que estoy
ignorando los problemas del sistema que
todos hemos vivido pero siento que en el
2021 hay muchos recursos a nuestro
alcance facebook tiene muchos cursos
gratis para mí la pobreza es una
mentalidad pienso igual cuando llegue a
esta ciudad
yo fui directo a un refugio muy de mi
familia por violencia tanto ciega la
mayoría de las personas no elige ser
pobre pero desde que llegué a los
ángeles he visto a muchos que no quieren
venir al refugio prefieren las calles yo
era pobre entre sí que he estado en
ambos lados de acuerdo y ahora puedo
darme cuenta del tipo de decisiones que
tomaba y las personas con las que me
contaba no creo que la pobreza sea algo
que podamos controlar desde que nace
englaro pero si siento que es un estado
que casi todos podemos cambiar si le
leemos mucha determinación y resiliencia
el resto puede acercarse
debemos entender que estas personas no
están en la calle porque quieren es
porque el sistema en el que vivimos
permite que pase sí si me permiten vengo
de una familia que vivía de la
asistencia social y ahora hago millones
de dólares en bienes raíces pero si
hubiese invertido entre 2005 y 2008
estaría en bancarrota no hoy tuve mucha
suerte muchos desean ser ricos pero no
quieren ser ricos la diferencia es hacer
algo dicho eso sí estoy de acuerdo con
que muchas personas en realidad no
tienen los recursos o la oportunidad
para crear un plan de acción no todos
queremos ser millonarios pero tampoco
quiero ser pobre me gusta el medio me
encantaría vivir en una sociedad que
saque a las personas de la pobreza con
programas que les den estabilidad eso me
gustaría
los billonarios no deberían existir
no creo que haya forma de gastar un
billón de dólares tener tanto dinero no
es una necesidad siento que existe una
cantidad con la que uno podría
sobrevivir y al mismo tiempo
prosperar sin ningún problema si pasas
ese límite
puedes estar sabes acaparando y ya hemos
visto lo que hacen los billonarios con
su dinero se van al espacio es obvio que
si pagarán más impuestos su riqueza se
distribuiría entre quienes la necesitan
y sería un mejor uso que ir al espacio
yo no tengo ningún tipo de problema con
que ellos existen para mí el problema es
que deben asumir las mismas
consecuencias que asumimos los pobres me
refiero al sistema judicial pero hay
algunos millonarios que han llegado a
donde están gracias a todo el valor que
han aportado a la sociedad voy a
mencionar a uno de ellos y ese es jaycee
es multimillonario y su música increíble
así que se volvió multimillonario no
creo que el gobierno debe intervenir y
decir tú tienes mucho lo vamos a quitar
eso nunca pasaría en ningún otro lugar
nadie dirá simon veil tiene muchas
medallas de oro te la vamos a quitar y
se la daremos a alguien que no es tan
talentoso como tú esta idea yo no estoy
de acuerdo ese es el deber del gobierno
tú lo dijiste jazzy hizo su dinero con
música es su trabajo es músico vende su
talento pero luego invirtió
el alcohol y uso a otras personas que
están cosechando el trigo el agave y se
rompen la espalda trabajando entonces no
deberían invertir en ellos deberían
votar sus sueños a la basura e irse no
trabajas para que te refieres tienen
trabajo
sí pero cuánto les pagan por eso como en
el tercer mundo donde ganan centavos
mientras james bond es gracias a ellos
dime cuánto le pagas a tus empleados
creen que la cosa está no existiría
sigue y si lo invierte puedo intervenir
yo les pago a mis empleados sumamente
bien y pueden escoger sus horarios una
es una mamá soltera y le pagó 50 dólares
la hora eres libre de odiar a las
personas que crean trabajo y
oportunidades pero nadie aceptaría un
trabajo que no valga la pena en ningún
sentido quien hace un billón de dólares
gana una fracción de esa suma todo el
que tenga un negocio puede entender eso
hasta jay si gana 50 centavos de cada
disco no es así pero esto se debe a que
la disquera lo explotó por su talento
ahora del dinero sigues diciendo lo
mismo
el negocio de la música yo lo conozco y
bien las disqueras apoyan cientos de
artistas sabes cuántos fracasan si bien
ellos se arriesgan con cada artista
pagan estudios pagan ingenieros mercadeo
etcétera los explotan los están apoyando
no pueden darles a todos un 50%
quebrarían no conoces este negocio y
solo gritas de explotar
los explotan y no millones como el esa
es la realidad exacto quiero hacerte una
pregunta cómo defines explotación y por
qué lo usas tanto me baso una definición
marxista donde tu trabajo crea un
importe que el empleador toma y lo
distribuye de forma desigual entre los
jefes y deja lo que sobra al resto en
sus explotaciones
me llamo de vida trabajo en disney en el
departamento de entretenimiento hago
cerca de 33 mil dólares al año como ha
sido la experiencia de trabajar en
disneylandia trabajar en disney es una
mezcla de experiencias las personas con
las que trabajo son increíbles pero la
compañía no es tan buena no nos pagan
mucho tienen suficiente dinero para
pagarnos más pero no quieren hacerlo por
eso formo parte de los sindicatos de
trabajadores
me llamo jean y tengo una agencia de
diseño de software y este año haré cerca
de 400.000 dólares cuando empecé mi
negocio eso consumía todo mi tiempo lo
único que hacía era trabajar por eso mi
pareja se sintió olvidada muchos de
nuestros problemas y también muchas de
nuestras peleas se debían a mi ausencia
la economía es manipulada
si tu familia es rica tienes más
oportunidades pero si eres pobre y
depende sólo de tu sueldo tienes que
postularse a trabajos que tal vez no te
gusten en vez de seguir tu pasión estoy
de acuerdo me imparte la economía si se
manipula para incentivar ciertas áreas
por eso hay tantos y tantos subsidios
agrícolas porque es importante si es
posible que busquen apoyar más a los
bienes raíces y la inversión del capital
que a otras pero no creo que la
manipulen para mantener al rico rico y
al pobre pobre no estoy de acuerdo
porque hay políticas como la de
reinversión que hacen las personas
productivas en el mercado de bienes
raíces y eso es algo bueno no creo que
persona productiva te refieres a los que
tienen dinero no me refiero a los que
toman ese dinero organizan un equipo lo
ponen a trabajar y generan valor eso es
una persona productiva pero los
trabajadores son quienes crean ese valor
hay personas que arriesgan su dinero y
producen más eso es valioso le estás
quitando crédito a una persona que pone
un riesgo ahorros bien para darle
capital a un proyecto y que le pagan de
último si el proyecto fracasa al
trabajador le pagan al que invierte no
si va bien el trabajador y el
inversionista ganan la inversión del
capital siempre se descuenta en
cualquier emprendimiento mi mamá no
quería ser rica quería dar clases
trabajar día a día y ser de clase media
y está bien pero gente como yo quiere
arriesgarse mucho para ganar mucho por
eso invertimos capital deberías
respetarlo
mi nombre es bill perkins tengo un fondo
de cobertura soy inversionista y manejo
mi propio dinero cuánto gano al año a
veces pierdo dinero pero gano unos 10
millones al año
cuide a mi padre en sus últimos años él
murió en la quiebra no heredé mi dinero
lo gane solo en realidad no me importa
el dinero es sólo una herramienta que me
permite vivir las experiencias que
quiero y hay muchas experiencias que no
quiero vivir junto en común la economía
es manipulada debes tener conciencia y
conocimiento para saber las reglas del
juego creo que existen ciertas barreras
que suelen evitar que algunos conozcan
las reglas pero creo que es posible
descubrirlas y acceder a ellas para mí
es lo primero y de acuerdo conozco las
reglas pero me dan asco por eso quiero
que me juegas el juego podría cambiar y
me dan asco no quiero jugar trabajo en
bienes raíces y podría tener millones
con los mismos vacíos legales que usa
donald trump para añadir impuestos y
sería una mala persona solo por seguir
la ley
y los harías en serio si
la ley está mal sí porque está mal me
refería que la ley siempre estaba bien
busca fomentar la inversión eso es lo
que quieren que inviertas la ley está
escrita para fomentar ciertas cosas y si
no te gusta intenta cambiarlo pero él no
es malo antes mencionaste que hay
barreras que mantienen a los pobres en
esas condiciones pero no todos conocen
las mentales yo también quería
mencionarlo porque si pienso en mí misma
recuerdo que cuando era pobre yo sólo
quería sobrevivir no tenía ni la
capacidad mental ni la fuerza de
voluntad para poder querer acceder a las
reglas de la economía pero un día tuve
una epifanía y dije no puedo vivir así
toda mi vida no me importa si me dicen
tonta cuadrada o insulta en mi color de
piel nada de eso me importa yo sólo
quiero salir hablando del color de piel
es que hay una correlación entre las
personas de la diáspora africana y la
pobreza no ves ninguna relación es
verdad que pertenecemos a una comunidad
que gana menos que otras comunidades es
cierto a menos mucho menos pero no debes
analizar las diferencias que hay entre
los grupos y culpar únicamente al
sistema el sistema tiene un gol muy
importante es la verdad y queremos
cambiarlo pero según las estadísticas
personas de mi antiguo vecindario y de
áreas cercanas gastan 50 por ciento más
en zapatos que personas de otros
vecindarios y para mí eso eso todo hace
poco leí un estudio que decía que en los
hogares asiáticos los niños estudian
entre 13 y 15 horas por semana mientras
que en un hogar negro son solo 3 horas
semanales dijiste que no es cuestión de
razas pero no recuerdas cómo llegamos
aquí los africanos se trataba de razas
no tuvimos la oportunidad de descubrir
américa como los otros siento que cuando
comparas de los hogares asiáticos y los
hogares negros
crees que a la primera comunidad la
crían de forma que les importen más sus
finanzas en nuestra comunidad prefieren
verse ricos que ser ricos es una
cuestión cultural es cultural y una
elección sí pero nuestra elección hasta
cierto punto cresta 2021 es una ahora
estamos en lo y es una elección no diré
lo contrario no lo es a que algunos no
tienen las mismas opciones que personas
de otras congreo que algunas personas no
tienen la capacidad mental para destinar
la energía necesaria para entender las
reglas del juego porque sus instintos
los obligan sea sólo sobre pero creo que
el trauma es un factor que casi no se
toma en cuenta el trauma me trajo aquí
mi familia es un culto islámico y no
estaba de acuerdo con cómo vivían y
enviaron a personas a matarme lo
intentaron muchas veces accedieron
totalmente a mis redes y a mis teléfonos
por eso no me gusta ignorar el trauma
como si ese factor no influyese en tus
capacidades porque las personas que
están traumadas y deben lidiar con
presión suelen tener menos opciones
eso es verdad sí mi nombre es khan y fa
y soy escritora y vivo en un refugio así
que no gano nada de dinero crecí en una
familia musulmana y el islam permite el
matrimonio entre primos así que mi
familia fomentaba los actos sexuales
entre primos por esta razón tuve que
huir de mi ciudad y venir a california
que está a 4 mil kilómetros de distancia
solo para que no me matarán no he sabido
de dónde vendrá mi próxima comida
mi pareja y yo estamos solicitando el
ppt porque hoy vale mi sueldo no alcanza
para mantenernos a ambos y soy el único
que trabaja porque le acaban de despedir
estamos intentando obtener ayuda del
gobierno para poder asegurarnos de tener
los fondos que necesitamos para nuestra
comida se siente tan se siente
obtener su ayuda no es tan fácil como
muchas personas dicen estar bien
tranquilas
que te quiten todo lo que tenías y no
saber dónde dormirás
a veces siento que esa vida en la que
tenía todo no era mía un día tuve que ir
a empeñar todos los bolsos y la ropa que
tenía para poder comprar dos pasajes
para mi hijo y para mí no teníamos
comida no teníamos un techo y no quiero
sonar como víctima pero nada es mi culpa
porque alzó la voz contra los cultos y
la pedofilia y publicar mi historia tuvo
un efecto dominó que me ha llevado a no
saber si podré comer y eso jamás me
había pasado hasta hace cuatro meses no
es nada fácil gracias por contar tu
historia no debe ser fácil si necesitas
ayuda podemos hablar luego de esto me
siento identificado con tu experiencia
porque mi madre nos crió sola y mi padre
la golpeaba también abusaba de niños
creo que todos saben a lo que me refiero
a si que te entiendo en serio no vales
de que tengamos tan poco tiempo porque
me gustaría escucharlos más a todos
escuchar las cosas que tienen para decir
en serio nosotros no hemos vivido así
desde hace tiempo desde hace mucho y
ustedes siguen en las trincheras no
visito las trincheras desde hace y
mi sueldo no es suficiente y además
tengo una terrible adicción a las
apuestas soy adicta a la yerba al
alcohol y a los pacers y tan pronto me
depositan mi sueldo pierdo todo el
control es casi como si fuese alguien
más y empiezo a apostar pido mucho
alcohol y también marihuana cuando salgo
de ese estado y tengo el control de
nuevo pienso cómo alimentar a mis
mascotas a mi gato a mi perro tenía
tantos planes antes de que me pagaran
pero lo gaste todo en un día y soy una
adicta cuando sabes que no tienes mucho
dinero y no puedes hacer mucho por
diversión y solo estás trabajando sin
parar para sobrevivir y alimentarte el
día que te pagan y tienes solo un poco
más de dinero que te permitirá sentir
algo de felicidad es tan difícil decir
no creo que lo ahorraré esta vez
prefieres aprovecharlo y darte un lujo
pero luego
entiendo lo que dices porque yo también
pensaba así pero luego empecé a pensar
en lo increíble que sería ser rica
preferiría no tener esa satisfacción
instantánea porque la satisfacción que
me da la estabilidad que tengo ahora es
mucho más importante me llamo brittany
soy proveedora de salud holística y gano
alrededor de 130 mil dólares al año mi
relación con mi hermano se ha derrumbado
desde que empecé a ganar más dinero solo
me llama cuando quiere algo la única
relación buena que tengo es con mi madre
no he hablado con mi hermano
aun quiero que ellos sean felices y que
tengan éxito en la vida pero se siente
terrible realmente que solo te busquen
por dinero y no por hermana o prima o
algo parecido me llamo mia y actualmente
trabajo en la atención al cliente de una
empresa de mudanzas y depósitos de 145
mil al año mi familia siempre me decía
que debía verme bien y cuidar mi imagen
cuando salíamos a comer oa comprar pero
como adulta no uso mi dinero para
comprar ropa nueva accesorios o
maquillaje o lo que sea dios o
pantalones franelas y por eso no me
siento
presentable y para ir a comer oa comprar
me invade un sentimiento de vergüenza
por no invertir más en cómo me presento
al mundo es punto en común no es sabido
de dónde vendrá mi próxima comida oigan
creo que no entendí la pregunta alguna
vez no estuviste segura de estar segura
te pasó
una vez me pasó cuando era estudiante
estaba haciendo compras a la señora de
atrás pago todo por mí sentí mucha
vergüenza porque mi tarjeta no pasaba y
no tenía el son horribles
15 dólares la hora no es un salario
mínimo suficiente
tengo una pregunta para los dos ambos
mencionaron que sufren adicciones y que
apenas les pagan lo que están apostando
en droga en compras o lo que sea y si su
ingreso fuese mayor eso cambiaría en mi
caso sí porque mi razón para apostar es
si gano los 60 mil dólares dejaré las
apuestas esa es mi mentalidad además yo
creo que si tuviese más ingresos pasivos
o si tuviese estabilidad financiera
podría dedicarle más tiempo a mis
verdaderas pasiones como quiero abrir un
canal de youtube sobre crímenes pero no
tengo computadora cuando la adicción me
atrapa no pienso en lo que no tengo solo
me siento
paralizada me pierdo siempre hago las
cosas sin pensar y creo que ese cambio
me ayudaría porque podría tener otras
distracciones que me benefician más si
tuvieses más dinero podrías buscar ayuda
médica tal vez un psiquiatra porque
suelen ser costosos no puedes costear
los con un salario mínimo siento que
muchos empleadores pagan salario mínimo
pero quieren un esfuerzo máximo pienso
que si me pagaras el mínimo me esforzaré
el mínimo en el trabajo siempre lo he
visto al revés si entro a una compañía
con sueldo mínimo vale lo que sea para
que me atiendan hola me llamo tot tengo
29 invierto en bienes raíces soy youtube
y gano 1.5 millones al año cuando creces
como yo sin dinero y una mamá que sufre
y llora todas las noches porque no puede
pagar las cuentas eso te cambia por
completo no exagero mi primer trabajo
fue a los 12 y recogí excrementos de
caballo por tres dólares la hora
recuerdo que me decía a mí mismo tienes
que ganar un millón de dólares al año
antes de los 30 me llamo song tengo 23
soy músico creo contenido y ganó al
mínimo trabajando como vendedor si no
tuviese que trabajar a diario para pagar
el alquiler tendría más tiempo para
hacer música conectarme con personas y
encontrar lugares para presentarme y si
tuviese dinero podría hacerle publicidad
a mi música para que más personas
escuchar
15 dólares la hora no es un salario
mínimo suficiente me gusta pensar que el
salario mínimo siempre es temporal se
aceptó ese sueldo digo bueno voy a
trabajar me esforzaré mucho para que me
atiendan y luego haré algo más con mi
vida hace muchos muchos años podías
vivir de la tierra no debías trabajar
para alguien para sobrevivir ahora esta
tierra tiene dueño y tampoco puedes
pescar en cualquier mar porque es ilegal
no es posible vivir así
si quieres sobrevivir debes trabajar
para alguien más y eso reduce tus
ganancias no puedes decir me largo voy a
relajarme y trabajar en mi libro o hacer
algo más ahí estoy de acuerdo con
ustedes yo apoyo la rb para que no todos
deban trabajar pero no estoy de acuerdo
con que le paguemos a las personas por
lo que necesiten dijiste algo similar si
me pagas poco trabajaré poco pero hay
trabajos que no deberían pagar 15
dólares la hora porque no vale la pena
valen 5 o valen 2 quiero que veas
televisión por una hora en tu casa y me
digas cuántos comerciales ves para uno y
te pagaré siete dólares la hora debería
pagarte 15 la hora por eso tomaría 7
dólares por sentarte en tu casa a ver
televisión y anotar comerciales
actualmente
piensan que el salario mínimo debería
ser 15 dólares no sí pero si fuesen 15
dólares perdimos un trabajo que le
estaba dispuesto a hacer
no más dinero más problemas
el dinero trae problemas pero es un
precio que estoy dispuesta a pagar
porque no quiero volver a tener los
problemas que yo tenía cuando era pobre
llegué a un punto en mi vida en el que
intenté acercarme a personas de las que
sentía que podía aprender algo recuerdo
que estacionaba mi pequeño y viejo auto
en un observatorio de griffith en
hollywood hills para estar rodeada de
dinero
ya les molesta si empiezo a la nada
muchos de los problemas que tengo se
resolverían con solo no necesito ser
rico solo más estabilidad tendría mucho
menos estrés menos preocupaciones y no
llegaría a estas situaciones en donde me
preocupa cómo pagar el alquiler cómo voy
a pagar la gasolina para el auto comida
más dinero significa más responsabilidad
social me muero como tú quieres decir si
eres un billonario entonces tienes la
responsabilidad de cuidar a las personas
que tengan menos que tú en serio empleo
lo que suceda falta
cometí mi primer delito a los 14 años
conduje abrió en 2018 y tuve que ir a
los tribunales me cuesta encontrar un
trabajo y que quieran entrevistarme me
hacen una oferta pero revisan mis
antecedentes y me rechazan luego veo a
las amas de casa de beverly hills
descubro que la hija de yolanda hadith
cometió el mismo delito que yo pero
puede ser modelo sin ningún problema a
nadie la rechazaría también he visto
casos de influenza como este niño que
condujo el auto de su padre mató a
alguien y salió por a
florestán rico para saber que algo está
mal no enfrentó las consecuencias lo
sabía pienso que él también merecía mis
castigos me equivoqué y siempre lo
aceptar lo que quieres es igualdad
exacto de cómo se siente con su la
cachetada de nuestro sistema judicial
eso no es justo amo la canción
pero tener mas maneiro hay diferentes
problemas si eso es todo lo logramos
terminamos
salimos porque creo que si no es pura ya
creo que es por aquí
[Música]